[Music]
while we wait for official avengers 4
news from the notoriously tight-lipped
crew at marvel here's a look at why
captain america is crucial to the
outcome of the war against
thanos and whether he'll still be
standing when those end credits roll
the biggest news to break regarding
captain america since the epic final
moments of infinity war
came to us in the form of a quick
goodbye note tweeted by none other than
chris evans himself
in only a few heartfelt words evans let
the whole world know that he would be
putting down his shield for good the
tweet which amassed
several hundred thousand likes within
hours read officially wrapped on
avengers 4.
it was an emotional day to say the least
playing this role over the last eight
years has been
an honor to everyone in front of the
camera behind the camera and
in the audience thank you for the
memories eternally grateful
maybe we'll see a cameo or two down the
road but for all intents and purposes
it does seem like this is the end for
steve rogers
infinity war might have been one of the
wildest rides in cinema history but
captain america's role in it was
actually
fairly minor sure we got a fun
re-emergent sequence for cap in the
fight at the train station in edinburgh
and his attempt to rally a crew of
heroes together to defend the world
against bad guys was a crucial part of
the plot
but even if captain america ultimately
received a decent amount of screen time
it did feel a bit like he was being used
to move the story forward more than
anything else
earth just lost your best defender so
we're here to fight
[Music]
and if you want to stand in our way
we'll fight you too the truth is captain
america ended up having a muted role in
infinity war the story had him stranded
in the middle of a sidebar conflict in
wakanda while
iron man took front and center on titan
it stands to reason that this will set
steve rogers up to be a crucial element
in the next chapter
where we'll almost certainly see more of
cap's storyline unfold
captain america civil war ended on a
pretty low note and many fans were
hoping for some on-screen
reconciliation between steve rogers and
tony stark in infinity war
in the end the two didn't even share a
scene the avengers broke up
we're toast broke up
like a band like like the beatles that's
not to say that the folks behind the
scenes didn't try to fit it in writer
stephen mcfeely explained that in the
original drafts of the script they had
steve and tony in the same room together
ultimately however he said as many times
as we wrote those scenes it became clear
that this movie needed to be propulsive
and be about thanos and what he
represented to the avengers
it may not have fit into infinity wars
plot but there's no way these two aren't
sharing some screen time in avengers 4.
their long-anticipated reconciliation
will no doubt be a pivotal scene and one
that sadly paves the way for cap's
demise
because once that breach is healed cap's
character arc will be nearly complete
just like a few of the other key players
in the mcu captain america's story arc
is in desperate need of closure
we've watched him rise up to lead the
avengers before entering into a
self-imposed exile
only to resurface for infinity war but
the character is still in need of a
final act to bring his story to an end
the russo brothers have been quiet about
what might happen after the third
avengers
only suggesting that infinity war was
quote the next
chapter so to speak in his specific
story and there's been no talk about
where we go beyond that yet
that comment could quite easily be used
to infer that after infinity war there
just
isn't much more left for steve rogers to
do in the mcu
one way or another he needs some closure
family
stability who wanted all that went in
the ice 75 years ago
i think someone else came out the truth
is steve rogers doesn't really have to
die in avengers 4 for a story arc to
wrap up
for chris evans to move on and for the
universe to be saved the only thing that
seems inevitable is that the character
won't be with us on a regular basis
during phase 4 of the mcu
how could this happen without a
heart-wrenching death scene rogers just
needs to pass the captain america torch
onto a successor
which could just as easily take place
after an epic comeback victory against
the mad titan there's a lot to be said
for quitting while you're ahead and how
much further ahead do you get than
defeating thanos
there's no shortage of rumors floating
about regarding who could replace steve
rogers as captain america whether it's
bucky barnes
sam wilson or even a complete wild card
chances are the mantle of captain
america will be passed on
the question is will steve rogers live
to see the passing of the torch or will
it be wrenched from his grasp
by thanos's hands